laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
allez dans quelques heures le début du
3ème confinement national à la veille du
week-end de pâques
les élèves ont quitté l'école
aujourd'hui pour rester 3 4 semaines à
la maison dans le même temps le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
indique que le nombre d'élèves
contaminée par le colis de 19 est passé
en sept jours de l'an dernier la plus de
28000 élèves par ailleurs on dénombre
plus de onze mille classes fermées un
chiffre qui a triplé en une semaine
[Musique]
du côté de la vaccination toujours cette
même lenteur en europe
au point que l'organisation mondiale de
la santé dans ce contexte lusage ou non
du vaccin sur bus foot ni vé alimente
les débats si la hongrie la slovaquie et
la république tchèque
l'on valide et d'autres pays comme la
france préfère attendre une potentielle
validation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
[Musique]
et puis au niger le président élu
mohamed bazoum a prêté serment cet
après-midi l'investiture deux jours
après un coup d'état militaire des
jouets et cela alors que le pays fait
face à une recrudescence des attaques
terroristes
le nouveau chef de l'état dénonce je le
cite de vrais crimes de guerre
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france et avant de
développer ces titres le capitole siège
du congrès américain à washington est
bouclée un homme aurait percuté deux
agents de police avec son véhicule la
police a riposté par des coups de feu le
suspect est à l'hôpital ainsi que les
deux policiers blessés
nous reviendrons sur cette information
dans courant de nos prochaines éditions
dans quelques heures le pays va se
soumettre à un confinement national le
troisième depuis le début de l'épidémie
cela va durer quatre semaines avec un
répit accordé en ce week-end de pâques
est les écoles ont fermé leurs portes et
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'éducation
nationale a dévoilé de nouveaux chiffres
le nombre de classes fermées à cause des
cas de coronavirus a triplé en une
semaine passant de 3250 à plus de onze
mille classes aujourd'hui elle est court
pour les écoles collèges et lycées se
feront donc à partir de lundi à la
maison pendant une semaine et puis ce
sera les vacances de printemps au niveau
national par ailleurs sachez que les
assistantes maternelles sont finalement
autorisé à garder les enfants selon des
sources syndicales on l'a appris
aujourd'hui à des mesures en tout cas de
restriction qui divisent les français on
voit cela avec florian lambert éducation
dernier jour de classe ce vendredi avant
la fermeture des écoles collèges et
lycées après les annonces des manuels
macron mercredi soir il faudra alors
patienter quatre semaines pour les
élèves avant de regagner leurs classes
une fermeture des écoles souhaité et
attendu pour certains français
effectivement les foyers dans les écoles
ça va très vite et ça peut se
démultiplier une vitesse énorme donc bon
bah toute façon il faut essayer
après sincèrement je pense que
voilà au point où on en est venu
faudrait peut-être arriver à faire un
confinement total pendant des semaines
et des semaines pour y éradiquer en fait
ce virus qui est en train de pourrir la
vie de l'agent font plus ça rejoint déjà
une vache et étudiantes du coup on en a
marre et en plus de cela on peut même
plus travailler on n'a pas de vacances
n'a rien c'est l'âge auquel me protéger
les jeunes et protéger les plus les plus
anciens à qui on pense pas vraiment pour
l'union nationale des syndicats
autonomes la fermeture des
établissements scolaires était
indispensable à condition toutefois de
lancer un plan de vaccination pour les
enseignants la dégradation rapide de ces
derniers jours et de ces dernières
semaines rendait le système on va dire
par contrôle de fonctionnement normal
donc c'était des mesures qui était
attendu et qui sont des mesures qui sont
satisfaisantes
après il y à un horizon qui est posée
la difficulté d'approvisionnement en
dose de de visibilité néanmoins le
gouvernement doit se mettre en capacité
de prévoir durant programmée de
vaccination pour les personnels pour
arriver en fait dans les meilleures
conditions pour que les écoles
l'établissement rouvre le plus
rapidement possible et dans les
meilleures conditions
un troisième confinement nationale une
fois de plus allégée des déplacements
interrégionaux proscrit un couvre-feu à
19h maintenu et une fermeture des écoles
pour quatre semaines
les français vont devoir une fois de
plus s'adapter aux mesures annoncées par
le chef de l'état dans les rues de la
capitale
l'annnonce de ces nouvelles restrictions
ne semble pas surprendre les français
oui je pense que tu as oms étaient
nécessaires pour que l'on puisse avancer
plus vite et puis avait des tensions et
des mesures à prendre pour que ce soit
plus restrictif
moi je pense que c'est pas assez il
faudrait être plus ferme et fermer deux
fois pour toute et mais ça on aurait dû
le faire comme il veut c'est moins beau
parce que là ça devient beaucoup plus
difficile de rester à la maison pour
cette fois ci je suis assez d'accord
je suis même totalement d'accord c'est
ce que j'aurais fait je suis pas
président de la république 1 mais je
pense que c'est exactement ce que
j'aurais fait il alla cette fois ci
c'est très bien je pense que ça a été
fait un peu trop tard après s'il faut en
passer par là j'ai envie de dire oui
pourquoi pas moi j'aurais été plus pour
un confinement un peu plus strictes déjà
il ya un mois ou deux
les mesures annoncées prendront effet ce
samedi soir et ce pour quatre semaines
de quoi laisser du temps et un répit au
gouvernement qui mise plus que jamais
sur une arrivée massive de vaccins pour
retrouver peut-être un semblant de vie
normale et l'exécutif à évoquer un
retour à la vie normale elle animait
avec une possible réouverture des lieux
de culture des bars et des restaurants
pour le moment à leurs portes restent
closes
idem pour les commerces dits non
essentiels à noter que certains restent
autorisés à recevoir du public ceux de
l'alimentation les librairies ou encore
les salons de coiffure en tout cas le
manque à gagner pour ceux qui baissent
le rideau est colossal écoutez à ce
propos christian baulme il est président
de l'association dès commerçants et
artisans les métropoles de france on a
été entendu sur les coques en un camp
tendue sur l'accompagnement alors
maintenant reste des mesures à prendre
mais qui font que
à l'europe pour vérifier qui ait pas de
distorsion de concurrence
on est en europe 1 quand même donc il y
à des mesures que le gouvernement ne
peut pas prendre comme ça donc le temps
de réponse de l'europe est plus long
donc on verra ce qui va arriver mais en
tout cas nous pensons que nous aurions
dû être confinés plus durement à la fin
des soldes pour reprendre fin avril au
plus tard
parce que le commerce redémarre à cette
époque de l'année
voilà là il ya un creux entre février et
mars
et donc c'est un temps de retard mais on
va faire avec
on va faire avec il ya tellement de
coups dans la raquette des mesures que
il faut qu'on change la méthode
d'attribution de l'aide et on va faire
un tour à du côté de la nouvelle
calédonie où la bac contrairement à la
métropole ont des confine
progressivement la propagation du virus
y est faible désormais donc il est
possible de circuler librement de se
rendre le voyez dans les cafés et les
restaurants et certaines mesures
persiste tout de même comme le port du
masque ou la fermeture des boîtes de
nuit on va écouter quelques réactions
recueillies sur place ce matin parce que
lui j'ai rencontré des gens je suis venu
j'ai vu des personnes des papas des
mamies se baigner le suis très content
elle pis voilà c'est ça le des
compliments je suis très heureuse
j'attendais ça avec impatience de voir
mon petit café au bord de la mer c'est
super c'est un super moment que
j'apprécie même s'il fait pas beau peu
importe le temps je vois du monde je
vois la mer sur tout et voilà bah c'est
super d'être des cons finis ça permet de
reprendre un peu l'air ça permet de
venir voir la mer de retrouver des amis
et et on a une petite pensée pour tous
les gens dans le monde qui eux sont
encore enfermés et pour permettre à ce
retour à une vie presque normale le
gouvernement que les gels de l'archipel
a mis en place une stratégie bien
particulière les explications 10 mètres
courte vie chill et historiens et
spécialistes
nouvelle calédonie notre gouvernement
d'abord il met à la disposition des plus
de 65 ans pour l'instant neuf mille
doses de vaccin
environ par semaine qui sont fournis
gratuitement par l'état
en suite de cela le gouvernement
collégial nous avons un gouvernement
collégial entamé une réflexion sur la
question de savoir s'il faut rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour
certaines catégories de personnes et
enfin le gouvernement travaille à un
en somme un styliste va s'inspirer de
celui là était mûr au point pour la
nouvelle zélande et que nous
connaissions un peu pour les cyclones
avec des deux red alert et des degrés de
précaution suivant le danger exprimé par
tel ou tel événement qui surviendrait à
la faveur des dépistages
donc voilà c'est sur ces trois choses là
le décompte de la nouvelle calédonie va
pouvoir se pérenniser parce que notre
gouvernement reste dans la stratégie que
notre pays reste un pays sans coville et
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils arrivent à
échéance l'agrément qui permet anticorps
de se constituer partie civile
il appartient matignon de le renouveler
ou non anticorps est l'une des trois
associations françaises qui lutte contre
la corruption dans le pays elle est déjà
mise en cause des élus ou personnalités
comme nous le précise david khalifa
reculer pour mieux sauter jean castex
doit tout de même tranchée une décision
plus difficile qu'il n'y paraît exigeant
des garanties le premier ministre a
rappelé avoir prorogé jusqu'au 2 avril
l'agrément d'anticorps qui expirait
originellement au 15 février le temps je
cite de recevoir les réponses aux
questions complémentaires posés par le
gouvernement
version officielle des faits mais en
réalité le problème se pose ailleurs et
le grand paradoxe c'est que le
renouvellement de l'agrément c'est une
décision qui appartient au gouvernement
alors que
un certain nombre de membres du
gouvernement ou de proches du pouvoir
sont concernés par nos actions donc jean
castex va de vraiment devoir faire
preuve d'une loyauté républicaine pour
renouveler cet agrément et je pense
qu'il est à des tensions qu'il ya des
appels pour ne pas dire qu'on ne pas
nous renouveler je pense que de diverses
personnes qui sont dérangés par nos
actions ou qui pourraient être dérangé
par nos actions un homme en particulier
représente cette fameuse tension dont
parle le vice président de l'association
eric dupond moretti
anticor a porté plainte contre le
ministre pour prise illégale d'intérêts
dans une autre affaire
le garde des sceaux ne pouvait donc plus
examinées l'instruction de l'agrément
d'anticorps par les services de son
ministère sans risquer le conflit
d'intérêts juridiquement le gouvernement
n'avait pas le choix
conformément à la réglementation les
ministres estimant se trouver en
situation de conflit d'intérêts en
réfère au premier ministre un décret
venant par la suite précisé les
attributions que matignon exercera à la
place du ministre concerné pendant la
durée de ses fonctions conséquence pour
que cette demande soit traitée de
manière impartiale la décision en est
revenu à matignon en revanche le service
chargé d'instruire la demande d'agrément
à partir lui à la direction de l'action
criminelles et des grâces un département
du ministère de la justice
placée sous l'autorité du garde des
sceaux lui même un lien de subordination
qui pose question le fait que la
direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces relève de l'administration du
ministère de la justice ne peut que
nourrir des interrogations sur
l'impartialité de la procédure le
dossier aurait pu être confiée à la
direction des affaires juridiques auprès
du cabinet du premier ministre
pendu à cette décision pour pouvoir
poursuivre son travail
anticor qui a relancé les affaires
richard ferrand et alexis kohler
notamment doit également faire face à
une crise interne de gouvernance depuis
le renouvellement son conseil
d'administration en mars 2020
une période compliquée et une attente
qui pourrait se prolonger pour
l'association
à moins que jean castex ne fassent
preuve de loyauté républicaine
c'est une affaire qui fait réagir le
monde associatif l'action anti
corruption d'anticorps elle est
indispensable pour de nombreuses
associations qui l'ont fait savoir dans
une lettre ouverte publiée sur le site
du huffington post une missive adressée
à jean castex pour demander au premier
ministre
le renouvellement de l'agrément et à ce
propos on va écouter khaled guy gillet
président des amis de la terre
associations signataires de la lettre
un truc en france c'est différent des
autres pays
il ya des pays où en gros les citoyens
en gros peuvent être considérés comme
une victime de la corruption ne sont pas
victimes directes et donc aller en gros
jusqu'au procès pour justement avoir en
fait le gain de cause
en france c'est le procureur en gros qui
décide ce une affaire est suivie ou pas
et il peut enterrer des affaires
et justement les associations qui ont
cet agrément d'agrément que demande
actuellement anticorps leur permettent
en gros de dire ben nous on n'est pas
d'accord avec le procureur on remet
cette affaire là en justice et on veut
en gros qui une enquête
et comme injuste voire d'aller jusqu'au
bout c'est très important parce qu'en
fait ça et vite
enfin il faut savoir que le procureur
qui qui qui traite la première affaire
n'est pas vraiment indépendants et les
relier à l'état d'où ces apports
importants ce type d'association face au
genre d'action
l oms pointent du doigt la vaccination
trop lente à l'échelle européenne
clément bonne le secrétaire d'état
français aux affaires européennes ne nie
pas selon lui il faut aller plus vite
déclaration ce matin chez nos confrères
de bfm tv
il a précisé aussi qu'aucun vaccin
produit par astrazeneca au royaume uni
n'a été livré aux vingt-sept dans ce cas
là il assure aucune dose ne quittera
l'europe à l'export / scouts nick v même
déclaration que la veille devant la
commission sénatoriale des affaires
économiques le vaccin russe ne sera pas
disponible en europe avant plusieurs
mois
il s'agit pas d'exclure par principe
politique par ce serait une erreur une
faute sanitaires et politiques de dire
le vaccin russe ne voudront pas parce
qu'ils les russes le vaccin russe il
doit faire comme tout le monde c'est à
dire déposé son dossier
s'il estime être suffisamment efficace à
l'agencé européenne du médicament pour
nous en remettons à 7 indique comment
européen c'est ce qui se passe il a
déposé tardivement son dossier mais il
l'a fait il a une première étape
d'examen qu'on appelle une revue
scientifique qui sans doute je suis pas
moi-même en charge évidemment et
scientifique mais qui sans doute nous
dit-on s'écoulera au moins jusqu'à la mi
juin et ensuite il ya une dernière étape
qui est l'autorisent l'avis de l'agencé
européenne du médicament sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché qui
prend encore quelques semaines donc ça
n'est pas un vaccin qui est autorise à
bhl vraisemblablement avant la fin du
mois de juin et je les dis il faut deux
critères simples pour qu'un vaccin soit
injecté dans les bras des français
qu'ils soient validées scientifiquement
c'est évidemment la moindre des choses
avec la même méthodologie pour tous les
vaccins
quelle que soit leur nationalité et qui
se produit aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'il est faible vent produits
peut-être que ça changera à l'été mais
il est faiblement produits il n'y a pas
une production massive de vaccins russe
que nous nous priverons ça n'est pas le
cas le vaccin qui attend toujours la
validation de l' agence européenne
médicament le vaccin russe son
utilisation et sa production divise
l'union européenne la france réticente
l'allemagne favorable mais prudente la
hongrie ou la slovaquie l'ont déjà
adoptée l'italie va produire le sérum
russe dès juillet du côté de mouscron
déplore que les questions de
géopolitique prennent le pas sur les
enjeux de santé publique écouter le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
le président russe vladimir poutine a
proposé une coopération internationale
dès les premiers jours
dès l'annoncé de la création du vaccin
vous vous souvenez comment la défiance
envers spoutnik gay s'est manifesté au
début ils ont dit que ce n'était pas
vrai puisque c'était de la propagande
réalisé dans le seul but de promouvoir
les intérêts politiques russes dans le
monde
nous entendons les échos de pouce la vo
30 mars de cette année là d'ymir poutine
a eu des pourparlers avec la chancelière
allemande angela merkel et le président
français emmanuel macron nous avons
senti une attitude plus réaliste une
volonté de coopérer plutôt que de tenter
de faire de la discrimination vaccinale
ou de la propagande vaccinale en
amérique latine spoutnik vais en tout
cas fait son chemin le honduras le
mexique le nicaragua ou encore le
venezuela l'ont approuvé depuis
plusieurs semaines idem en argentine où
les plus de 70 ans se font injecter le
sérum russe on voit cela avec grégoire
douchy
l'accès au vaccin spoutnik v c'est ce
que propose ce centre de vaccination
situé aux abords du stade 2 qu'il messe
dans la province de buenos aires
ce sont pour l'instant les argentins
âgées de plus de 70 ans qui ont accès au
sérum alors que le pays est en pleine
deuxième vague
nous avons besoin de solidarité nous
avons besoin que chacun soit responsable
pour que cette deuxième vague et que
nous traversons déjà ne se termine pas
par un effondrement du système de santé
aujourd'hui avec elle-même nous sommes
entre 60 et 70 % d'occupation des lits
de soins intermédiaires et des lits de
soins intensifs également spoutnik v
reçoit un franc succès parmi les pays
latino américains ils sont désormais une
dizaine d'états avoir approuvé le vaccin
développé par la russie une campagne de
vaccination qui suscite l'espoir chez
les argentins qui reçoivent leur
première dose c'est ma première dose et
dans trois mois ce sera la deuxième
j'attends le vaccin parce que j'ai la
conviction que nous allons sortir de
cette crise et pour cela il faut des
choses comme la vaccination avec un peu
de chance ça sera fini après une sortie
de crise que les autorités espèrent
rapide à ce jour l'argentine a
enregistré environ 2 millions 300 mille
cas de covin 19 pour près de cinquante
six mille décès l'inquiétude de l'union
européenne des etats-unis après que la
russie a déplacé hier des troupes à sa
frontière avec l'ukraine qui a fas
dénonce des tentatives de pressions de
la part de moscou
joe biden s'est entretenu avec son
homologue ukrainien volodimir zelensky
il s'est engagé à soutenir la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et le
porte-parole du kremlin estime lui que
cela ne représente une menace pour
personne
la correspondance à moscou de vera
goffman les forces armées russes n'ont
jamais participé et ne participe pas aux
conflits armés sur le seul
l'ukrainien a affirmé le porte-parole du
président russe dmitri peskov
1 expliquant l'augmentation de la
présence militaire russe à la frontière
avec l'ukraine
lors de son entretien quotidien avec les
journalistes pour lui le fait que la
russie effectué le transfert de ses
forces armées
à l'intérieur de son propre territoire
ne doit enquêter personnes comme cela ne
pose aucune menace à personne je vous
propose d'écouter certains scénario
pareil provoquerait une nouvelle
escalade des tensions près des
frontières de la russie d'un évidemment
cela exigera des mesures supplémentaires
de la part de la russie pour assurer sa
sécurité
la fédération de russie nos menaces et
n'a jamais menacé personne c'est sur
cette base que repose notre position
malheureusement la situation réelle sur
la ligne de contact est effectivement
très effrayante
il y à des provocations de la part des
forces armées ukrainiennes
il ne s'agit pas de cas isolés ils sont
multiples quant à la rhétorique
je viens de répondre à une question
concernant les déclarations de kiev sur
la nécessité d'engager les forces armées
de l'otan
j'estime que les déclarations de ce type
parle d'elle-même
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères andreï rudakov à son tour
qualifié les spéculations quant au
conflit imminent entre la russie et
l'ukraine d'une fac nous écouter je suis
convaincu que toutes les spéculations
concernant une sorte de conflit imminent
entre l'ukraine et la russie est un
nouvel exemple de fake diffusé en
premier lieu par les autorités
ukrainiennes
la russie est intéressée par aucun
conflit avec l'ukraine
surtout militaire nous ne savons en
aucune manière les efforts de l'eau à
eux
la russie a voté pour la prolongation du
mandat de la mission spéciale
d'observation qui vient d'être
renouvelée avant-hier et espère que l'ol
se continuera de contribuer au règlement
de la situation en ukraine et à
l'atténuation des tensions dans le
donbass notamment dans le cadre des
activités de la mission spéciale
d'observation je rappelle qu'il s'agit
de la montée des tensions entre moscou
et kiev à la suite des exercices
militaires russes menés en crimée
au niger jour d'investiture pour le
nouveau président mohamed bazoum qui
succède à mamadou issoufou il a prêté
serment aujourd'hui dans la capitale
niamey une investiture deux jours après
une tentative de coup d'état menée par
des militaires à cela s'ajoutent les
attaques terroristes récurrente on
rappelle que sa victoire elle a été
contestée par l'opposition dont l'ex
président mahamane ousmane finalistes de
la présidentielle
on va écouter un extrait du discours
d'investiture de mohamed bazoum chef de
l'état nigérien a décliné ses grandes
ambitions avec en toile de fond le
renforcement de la démocratie
ses grandes ambitions ne saurait se
réaliser aussi longtemps que notre pays
sera confronté à l'insécurité générée
par l'existence de groupes terroristes
dont la barbarie vient de dépasser
toutes les formes
à l'occasion des tueries qu'ils ont mené
cette année dans les départements de
ouallam bani-bangou et il ya pendant
longtemps les criminels embrigadés dans
l'état islamique dans le grand sahara et
ges affiliés à d'arrêt mais s'attaquer
quasi exclusivement qu'aux forces de
défense et de sécurité
mais depuis incertaine car ils ont
commencé à s'en prendre au chef du
village puis progressivement aux civils
de façon indiscriminée
depuis janvier dernier et se livre à des
massacres de civils innocents à grande
échelle comme état à l'occasion des
vrais crimes de guerre et les coups
d'état a presque une tradition niger
lorsqu'il ya un blocage politique c'est
la vie de léon kong où il est
politologue spécialiste des relations
internationales
c'est la scène politique est bloquée
lorsque gouvernement et les oppositions
ne parviennent pas à s'entendre pour
désherber la paix
l'armée s'est toujours présenté un
premier temps gokhran de l'institution
étatique passé on assiste à des cadets
une position suit la scène politique et
des périodes de travail
lyon quasi interminables et compte tenu
de la situation que l'on vit depuis
pratiquement la proclamation ou alors
des pays de second tour intervenu au 21
février et la proclamation des résultats
par la suite le pays vit sous tension
tension a entraîné un parti à savoir la
partie qu'il a rapporté monsieur mohamed
bassong et des love hotels est trop
varman ancien président de la république
et qui n'a pas connu la victoire
frais de mission pas si c'était en
france à sept situations que l'armée
comme d habitude a voulu intervenir des
petites robes en birmanie au sein de
sushi est accusé d'avoir violé une loi
sur les secrets d'état datant de
l'époque coloniale
l'ex dirigeante birmane est poursuivi en
justice également pour d'autres motifs
d'incitation à l'ordre public et podevin
elle est détenue depuis le coup d'état
militaire du 1er février et pour la
première fois depuis le putsch ses
équipes de défense ont plus la voir par
vidéo est sous surveillance policière
elle risque une longue peine de prison
en tout cas sur le plan diplomatique
l'onu condamne la répression qui a tué
des centaines de civils mais pas de
sanctions la chine s'y refuse et appelle
au dialogue écouter le porte-parole de
la diplomatie chinoise
la chine espère sincèrement que toutes
les parties et factions en birmanie
garderont à l'esprit les intérêts à long
terme du pays et de la nation lanceront
le dialogue et la consultation dès que
possible et aplanir leurs différences
dans un cadre constitutionnel et
juridique je suis afin de faire avancer
le processus de transformation
démocratique durement acquis le reste de
l'actualité internationale en bref à et
en images à présent les états unis
ouvert à des discussions directes avec
l'iran sur le nucléaire iranien
un pas timide vers un retour au sein de
l'accord de vienne signer en 2015
washington devrait participer à une
prochaine réunion mardi à vienne avec
les grandes puissances signataires qui
se sont d'ailleurs retrouvés aujourd'hui
avec l'iran à l'initiative de l'union
européenne mais ce n'est pas encore
gagné car téhéran refuse de négocier
selon un tweet de son chef de la
diplomatie
quatre casques bleus ont été tués dans
une attaque dans le nord du mali c'était
ce matin un bilan provisoire qui fait
état également de 16 blessés il s'agit
de soldats tchadiens de la mission de
l'onu la minus ma dans un communiqué
elle a condamné cette attaque terroriste
je cite ignoble destiné à entraver le
processus de pêcher et puis le g7 tape
du poing sur la table à propos du tigré
cette région dissidentes au nord de
l'ethiopie ils exigent le retrait rapide
des forces érythréenne venus en aide à
l'armée gouvernementale qui a mise au
pas les forces locales en novembre
dernier
ce retrait sera l'engagement pris par
addis abeba et à smara qui ont
d'ailleurs démenti la présence des
forces érythréenne dans la région
et avant de conclure cette édition cette
information pour rappel le capitole
siège du congrès américain à washington
boucler un homme aurait percuté deux
agents de police avec son véhicule est
la police a riposté par des coups de feu
le suspect est décédé selon les médias
américains elle et deux policiers
blessés ont été transportés à l'hôpital
voyez ici donc ces images en direct
on le rappelle le capitole qui a été
l'objet d'un assaut meurtrier
c'était le 6 janvier dernier un assaut
mené par des manifestants pro trump on
s'en souvient
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans 30 minutes pour une nouvelle
édition rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative au temps
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant